il s'est tenu ce mardi 15 décembre au
programme les prévisions budgétaires
pour l'année à venir alors il n'y a pas
plus de dépenses engagées par rapport à
l'année dernière puisque le budget
global de 1021 s'élève à 16,2 millions
d'euros prévus contre 16,3 en 2020 ce
budget on le rappelle ne se substitue
pas aux budgets départementaux le pays
yves in hauts-de-seine permet de
réaliser des économies grâce à une
mutualisation des services à une mise en
commun des marchés c'est ce qu'on
appelle les économies d'échelle comme on
passe des commandes en volume beaucoup
plus importante les entreprises ajustent
leurs prix plutôt à la baisse et c'est
ce qui génère ces économies qui permet
de faire que ce service qui est un
service de proximité reste un service de
proximité tout en étant globalement plus
économique pour nos de budget si je
prends un exemple qui en terme de
travaux de voirie
le fait de travailler ensemble et de
passer des marchés en commun nous avons
économisé 15 % entre l'an dernier et
l'année qui a suivi
concrètement en 2021 et comme chaque
année trois grands domaines
d'investissement mutualisé entre les
départements l'entretien et
l'exploitation du réseau routier
départemental qui dispose d'une
enveloppe de 12,9 millions d'euros
l'archéologie préventive avec 630 mille
euros prévus et enfin l'adoption avec
147 milles euros
un projet ressort quand même par rapport
aux autres c'est la maison destinée aux
autistes
un projet qui selon le président du
département des hauts de seine est rendu
possible grâce à le pays et ça c'est un
très beau projet que n'aurions pas mener
individuellement et qui va permettre à
de nombreuses familles de pouvoir avant
leurs enfants encore à proximité plutôt
que de partir en belgique elle la
question reste la suivante les deux
départements vont ils finir un jour par
fusionner une interrogation qui pourrait
être l'un des enjeux des prochaines
élections départementales en juin
prochain